how can the Parliamentary process be
considered to be at all transparent when
there's one donor who's given the
address of a derelicts building there's
another one that is a firm of
accountants who uh ah we must assume the
proxies of the true donor and are they
pay thereby maintaining the donors
anonymity so my question would be what
are the implications of donor anonymity
for our country and our democracy
this is quite a big issue isn't it Henry
I mean my poor colleague Sam uh Sam coat
has been scouring the country knocking
on doors for uh donors whose names are
are in the record but finding empty
offices with wet carpets and all the
rest of it
it's not good no and I I think this is a
regulatory problem now I might it might
be wrong because you've been
investigating this or not and I haven't
but as I understood it actually donor
donor anonymity is not allowed in the
United Kingdom there was a there was
actually a fury a bit of a fury during
the brexit referendum because it was for
reasons Terror related allowed in
Northern Ireland for a while and there
was a big donation via the dup to the
the pro-brexit campaign but that was
specifically allegedly because there was
a gap in the Northern Ireland I don't
think you you shouldn't be able to have
donut anonymity of that sort and if it's
currently occurring that is a failure of
the regulator that needs to be policed I
think the bank account cannot be
anonymous but we don't necessarily need
to know who we're not necessarily
allowed to know who holds a bank account
we'll just just to identify what the
what the real problems are that we've
had and it is yeah and it is a point
worth making that for all the MPS
declarations that you know our system is
very transparent it's taken a team of
people from two newsrooms nine months to
try and make sense of this I think you
know Bob kersnick's point is absolutely
right the vast majority of people there
is this public service and the truth is
that actually on the vast majority of
donors you don't knock on the door and
not know who's there actually you can
see it pretty clearly
the problem that you've got is that a
number of donors do disguise themselves
that's a problem the second problem is
the MPS report how money is given in a
bunch of different places using a bunch
of different databases and PDFs and
whatnot so it's really hard to actually
make sense of it all together I think
the benefit of the Westminster accounts
is it does all come together in one
place and then you can begin to identify
the ones that simply don't make sense
and then you go out and investigate them
and indeed I can I can say with
authority because I had to look at look
at it to present this show it does help
a lot